Think what's gonna happen in the general election.
I'm gonna stand here again,
I'm gonna take the fight again to the other
other parties
and we're gonna do much better in the general election.
What is this achievable
in a year span that will see the general election?
Is this something that's achievable
in the next 10 years?
You say that you want to be a party in power,
but isn't it really just a party to
split the conservative vote right now? Not at all.
I'm not in politics to split the conservative vote.
When I joined Reform UK,
I did it to obliterate the Tory party.
Well, they've kind of beaten me to it.
What we are is a genuine
democratic choice for the British people.
I believe, and I think people understand and accept
and also believe that the country
as the way it's been governed at the moment,
is facing an existential threat.
You can't have open borders,
you can't have debt going through the roof
like we've had,
you know, post World War 2.
High in debt, taxation,
GDP shrinking.
6 million people,
uh, you know,
surviving on Universal Credit.
This is a broken economy.
We need a rapid change of direction.
Only reform UK offers that change of direction.
We need to get bombs on green seats
so we can change the way this country is governed.